hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are doing
another of my monthly q and a's
this video is sponsored by keeps we will
hear more from them in a little bit
but let's just jump straight into the
question first question very relevant
one i thought that i would oh by the way
i'm so bad at pointing over the right
shoulder i'm at the beach
um just a great filter on my microphone
so you can't hear the wind it's lovely
out here
the first comment is from sudira18 that
says what do you look like without
makeup can we see it no hate just
curious
uh so i just thought that i would do
this q a with no makeup uh there is a
ton of content of me
not wearing makeup on the internet um
and i find the frequency that i get
asked this question odd because of how
much
content there is of me not wearing
makeup you can see it and probably have
before
oz biba oh said how will sony manage its
first party exclusives on pc are they
going to release them all with a delay
or keep the bigger first party
franchises naughty dog in santa monica's
got a war exclusive
this is complicated i'm sure it's a
studio by studio basis in a game by
basis but i can picture a world where
the studios that have sony and their
name
stay strictly on playstation and the
ones that don't could go to pc so you
could see
sucker punches ghost tsushima on pc or
naughty dogs the last of us on pc but
you won't see god of war obviously being
from sony santa monica
or days gone obviously being from sony
ben because i believe from my
understanding of sony structure
the companies that have sony in the
title um do function
a little bit differently and and have a
even
tighter relationship with sony than the
ones that don't who have like a small
amount
more autonomy that's a wild guess
because you asked me the question
i would not throw that out if you
haven't directly asked me the question
very speculative next up lucas mckibbin
said do australians really say crikey
and if so what is the proper use of it
honestly not really and every time that
i answer an australia specific question
i always want to
start off with the disclaimer that it
varies depending on where you're from
australia is a big country just like
america so um
no australians in my life say crikey or
ever really have but i don't imagine
it's unheard of and i believe
the correct use is
something is shocking or surprising
crikey crikey mate
is basically like gonna be the correct
delivery there
seems pretty self-explanatory i think
steve owen had it right
this is a tasty one uh it says alana i
really used to trust you but after what
you said about halo infinite i just
don't understand how i should listen to
anything you say anymore
that's part one you shouldn't i never
ask you to listen to anything that i say
i just share my opinions oh sorry i
almost missed this and then it also says
how on earth could you defend this game
well part two i'm sorry but can you
explain how you found the game demo so
amazing
uh this has been very interesting to
watch unfold
i would have to ask you what do you
think i said about halo
infinite my guess based on this question
is that you think that i've said
something about halo that i haven't
actually said
i've definitely seen people lying about
things that i've said recently where
halo specifically is concerned
um i've had people say that i thought
that it was perfect or like amazing and
i don't think i ever even used the word
amazing um to give you my actual stance
on halo infinite
and i've been very very open and
transparent and subjective about how i
feel about this and i feel like i've
owned this subjectivity i've always said
well this is how i feel and this is why
i feel that way
so from the jump all i've said about
halo infinite um
even before we saw gameplay was i
really love halo133 and i really love
odst and reach
meaning i love the bungee halos i don't
care for halo 4 and 5
and all i wanted from a new halo was for
it to look like halo
1 through 3 honestly so before we saw
infinite reveals
um that was always my thing was like
just make it look like old halo that's
that's what i want from halo right now
otherwise i'm not going to be interested
in it we saw gameplay
it looked like original halo probably to
the extent that a lot of people are
making fun of it for looking bad but for
me
it looked like the silent cartographer
so i think in everything i've said about
it all i have said
is it looks like old halo that's what i
wanted it to look like so i'm happy
um i never said anything like it looks
next-gen it looks incredible
it's going to be a system seller like
i've never said any of this hype
[ __ ] that people
are saying that i said i never said any
of it it's all lies
so to say please explain how you find
found that game demo so amazing
um yeah if you look at literally
everything i've said about halo across
the board the the genuine answer to why
i found it so amazing which again
quote i never think i actually said is
that it looks like old halo that's what
i want
i want them to play into the nostalgia
um when i had my behind closed doors
demo and i got to ask some questions to
the team they kept speaking about how it
is a spiritual successor
to the first games and how they really
wanted to go back to their roots so all
of that as an og halo fan made me very
happy so that would be my explanation
but i think the layered explanation
is don't believe everything you read on
the internet um someone
spread it somewhere that i said that
halo infinite was a six month old build
and that's why it looked that way
i didn't say that my exact quote was
they did say it's an earlier build i
said they did say it's an earlier build
that's all i said um which is just me
reporting on what a microsoft employee
told me
not to me uh spreading a lie about it
being six months old
or anything like that um and i guess
where the delays are concerned my stance
is the same as it has been for
everything else ever which is if game
needs to be delayed then delay it
that felt like a long answer and now for
the sponsored part of this video
let's talk about keeps for the next 60
seconds ad read voice
did you know two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left but hey you can also get
treated from home oh sorry
you used to have to go to the doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
now thanks to keeps you can visit a
doctor online and get hair loss
medication
delivered right to your home okay the
next part is particularly really
important um
keeps off his generic options of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there if you don't know what that
means i feel like i should do an
american voice for this one the fda is
responsible for protecting public health
by regulating human drugs and biologics
animal drugs medical devices tobacco
products food including animal food
cosmetics and electronic products that
emit radiation that was really hard
basically they care about your safety
and i have not personally tried keeps
but i do have one close personal friend
who has who had actually a genuinely
very positive experience so
uh do have that anecdotal bit to share
with you guys too
so if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
alana pierce or click the link in the
description to receive 50
off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash
alana pierce lofrenzo said what's your
favorite weapon to use in any video game
i have like two very specific ones that
stand out to me for this
my favorite weapon in any video game is
gonna be bfg
specifically in doom 2016. otherwise i
absolutely adore the chakrams in
kingdoms of amolor and it's worth
mentioning that the re-release for that
comes out on the 8th
i'll probably stream it because i really
liked that game i was super into it i
always looked at the combat in that game
as being like what i would want a modern
fable to be like
um it's just cool like throwing discs
that come back to you it was just it was
dope i also think that uh
titanfall 2 has a lot of great weapons
um
that you know some of which extended it
into apex as well eight bit booty nice
said do you watch any other content
creators on youtube top five
i don't watch any content creators on
youtube
literally at all i spend all of my spare
time playing video games you guys might
already know i don't really watch tv
um don't watch a lot of movies except if
they're in cinemas which i was watching
virtually every movie that came out
because i do that as a social thing
you get to do a social thing where i
don't have to talk to anyone but they
still saw when i showed up
hey if i were to list one i honestly
think the youtuber that i've watched the
most this year is
probably sarastero or i guess it's
sarastro not saras turo
um he paints miniatures and it is
wonderful
that's probably it eddie asks where do
you hope to see your youtube channel in
the near future
i've been getting close to um 500 000
subscribers is super exciting
and and i i you know never would have
imagined that happening when i started
this channel
um which for anyone who's new here i
started because i wanted to learn how to
edit
i was already writing in the industry um
i think i maybe had done a little bit of
presenting and i recognized that video
stuff was important and that i needed to
like expand that skill set so i started
this channel
a to get a little bit more comfortable
on camera and b to learn how to edit
that said very related to that
um i don't have really goals for this
channel it is very much just a thing i
do for fun
a place where i can talk about stuff
that i can't necessarily talk about
on like work platforms not that i don't
still do plenty of that at inside gaming
and i am uploading way more right now
and have been in the last three months
than i ever have before in the entire
history of this channel
just because i'm isolating alone and
it's like good to have something to
constantly work on to stay motivated
outside of my actual job which frankly
is also full-time hours but you know
when you're locked in an apartment by
yourself you gotta make stuff
sometimes because i can't do much else
captain wilt said hi leonard i'm
starting university in a week for a
degree in digital media and your years
in the industry what's the number one
thing you'd
say you've learnt in that time frankly
that no matter what i do
people will tell me that everything i
have ever achieved is because i'm a
woman
i've definitely learned that literally
no matter what i do or how much
experience i have
it will happen forever but that's not
something that's useful for me to
transfer to you
um i think one thing that i would say
that i think has very much helped me
when i was a journalist to both stand
out and has kept me informed
now is listening to investor calls a lot
of journalists don't do it
a lot of uh the public won't do it but
if you listen to investicles and you
watch their
um basically like company presentations
sure that takes time a lot it sounds
very boring because it's the business
side of stuff but i feel like it
informed me in a very unique way that
has continued to be valuable
that will also make you stand out um as
a journalist if that's what you're
trying to do you didn't specify here but
because a lot of other journalists
won't do it um so i highly recommend
staying on top of
how the business side of the industry
runs seeing who is in what position
what company structure changes mean uh
because then you can actually provide
information to an audience that they
generally won't seek out themselves
which is also because the business side
of stuff can be a little bit boring and
that is something that i definitely
learned at the time is pay a lot of
attention to
investors pay a lot of attention to the
stock market pay a lot of attention to
who is running what at what company and
if they're publicly traded
it informs how they release things in
what release dates and what quarters
uh their marketing budgets all of that
stuff um
just gives you a perspective that i
think is very helpful if you're in the
industry in a professional capacity mike
g
said i've noticed that the only fun
house videos you are regularly in are
the gta ones do you have any plans of
doing some sort of series on the channel
i'd really enjoy that thank you
um i just started a series the first
video is up and
uh i guess we would probably start
releasing them more frequently if that
got a lot of views
which was my pitch and um we have
recorded i think three of them so far
which is favorite game i had everyone at
funhouse give me a list of their
favorite games and it
is me and ryan on every single episode i
decided to have me
probably as the person on the channel
who knows the most about video games and
will have played everything
i would suspect that uh everyone else is
playing
it's totally not to discredit everyone
else they're all gamers it's just
i play a lot of [ __ ] video games i
don't know what you want me to say and
then ryan who knows the least about
video games to balance it out
so the idea is the person whose favorite
game it is is showing us their favorite
game
i can like add anecdotes to what they're
showing us and then we kind of ask ryan
what he thinks of it so he's like almost
rating everyone else's favorite games
so that's planned to be a recurring
series probably one a month again if it
gets more views we could probably
increase the frequency
but it's been really fun to record uh
because i also recognize that when we
did our animal crossing
tours which i planned and produced those
videos as well
people really liked the wholesome nature
of it so i was like okay let's
like expand on that keep these videos
funny and silly with obviously like ryan
reading people's favorite games but also
have different fun house members like
enthusiastically talking about their
favorite thing because people like to
see that kind of wholesome content so
yeah that is uh uh currently another
recurring series that i'm doing there
ben w said any plans to invite guests
from your troy austin or mike's
respective corners of the game industry
on future episode of play was justin
bieber [ __ ] that sentence up loving the
podcast so far oh thank you ben
uh look we've discussed this and it may
happen in the future
but the truth is that podcast came
together not because i picked a random
voice actor and a random composer and a
random director
um i certainly did you know pitch it to
them as that being the hook
but it's those four people because those
four people have such good chemistry
we really respect each other have solid
diversity of opinion
disagree with each other frequently so
it's very much about the conversation
flowing in the way that it does because
of those four people
um who obviously can also speak to their
various vocations and do in a very
informed
and i think passionate way but it's
entirely possible that if you removed
one of those pieces and added someone
else in
the show would feel completely different
so i'm hesitant to do it because the
chemistry is the selling point
and i really love that about the show um
but i can imagine if like
someone absolutely can't do one week
that we would have a guest on instead
josh keaton fan said why are you no
longer on inside gaming anymore
i get this question so frequently that
i've started to wonder if it's a meme
and that i'm just not in on the joke
i'm on inside gaming three days a week
and when you asked this question
three weeks ago i was on inside gaming
three days a week sometimes four or five
days a week
like how do i get this question so
frequently
people also are like why did you stop
being on fun house videos
and i'd be like my last video on
funhouse was yesterday when people ask
this question do they not look fast
it's very confusing is this a meme
that i just missed i don't understand
i guess the answer is i am still on
inside gaming and i don't know how you
missed it
game guy said for the next q a do you
ever plan on sharing more about your
writing
um so for anyone who's not following me
on other social media i did share that i
recently finished
a book that i had been writing for ages
it took a long time i am good at working
on the deadline when it is
self-inflicted
not quite as good so i gave myself the
deadline of my birthday and did manage
to get it done
i have this thing where i think i
mentioned it before that i have no
interest in getting published
um i think maybe i would do it if i
could figure out some way to tie it into
charity or something like if i felt like
i was
doing it for some reason because when it
comes to me just publishing it on my own
i just have no motivation to do that and
i was talking about this
on uh my podcast which is here on this
channel play watch listen check it out
recently that i actually i hadn't
figured out why i felt that way
um why i didn't care about publishing
anything that i write and i think it
might come from
my dad when i was a kid wrote this kid's
book about a bee called rosiby
he even had art made for it he made
songs to go with it
uh never published it it was just this
book that existed basically for my
sister and i and i have never really
thought about how cool that was
and i imagined that influenced me going
forward for sure
that growing up with this full kids book
with all these characters in these songs
that i
i still to this day could recite that
nobody else would ever understand
probably meant that i also don't care
i'll share what i wrote with people but
i know personally otherwise i don't care
also i feel like anyone who's watched a
lot of my q as or even streams recently
probably knows that the next step that i
want to take in my career is definitely
that i want to write a video game so
when i do that
which i will it'll happen eventually
then in theory you would see my writing
um but i don't know i'm still figuring
it out
alrighty you guys i think that's pretty
much it uh thank you all for watching
am i out of focus again really having
trouble with this huh webcam is it
because of the
no i was about to say something really
stupid i was about to ask if it's
because
of the video of the palm tree behind me
but naturally
my webcam is not perceiving that because
it is green screened on and not actually
visible
to my webcam i put shame on my family
for even
being about to ask that question i'm
sorry everyone
good day